George a 46 ans un accident une perte
d'emploi tout bascule depuis un an il
vit dans la rue sans domicile fixe mais
pas sans cœur hier il s'est transformé
en Père Noël il a pris son sac de pièg
jaune récolté la semaine dernière 214
francs et en a fait don au service de
pédiatrie de l'hôpital de Bon Secours à
messe au plus grand étonnement des
enfants et des infirmières leur réaction
était de se dire que finalement il avait
rien et que il était capable de donner
et on s'est demandé si nous-même on
aurait autant de générosité aujourd'hui
veille de Noël anonyme George a repris
sa place dans la rue c'est c'est la
nouvelle génération qui va nous suivre
alors je voudrais pas que ça leur arrive
viv dans la rue j'ai choisi un hôpital
parce que ce sont des enfants qui n'ont
pas la chance de passer un Noël chez eux
et alors j'espère que le geste le geste
que j'ai
fait ce soir il réveillonnera seul avec
son petit chat c'est son souhait autre
souhait recommencer son geste l'année
prochaine pour tenter de faire plus
encore